hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will discuss
some of the most important digital
marketing tools and the skills needed to
become a digital marketing expert stick
to the end of this video to get detailed
knowledge on digital marketing digital
marketing tools and digital marketing
skills but before we begin consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
from us that's it if these are the types
of videos you would like to watch then
hit the like And subscribe button and
the bell icon to get notified and just a
quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master digital
marketing skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learn's cohort of various
digital marketing programs simply learn
offers various certification and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like SP gen Purdue and meta
through courses you will gain knowledge
and work ready expertise in skills like
search engine marketing strategies for
paid campaigns analytics Roi and
evaluation and over a dozen others and
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire product companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a
digital marketing role as a fresher or
moved on to a higher paying job and
profile
if you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comment
and description box to find a digital
marketing program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest we have
reached the end of this session on
digital marketing tools should you need
any assistance PP and other resources
used in this session please let us know
in the comment section below and our
team of experts will be happy to help
you as soon as possible greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders from Simply
learn and today we're going to talk
about digital marketing careers jobs and
resumés so welcome and let's get started
so we live in a world where everything
is digitized whether we're communicating
reading watching interacting everything
is digitized and one of the benefits of
our digitized world is opportunities and
those opportunities have Arisen in the
world of digital marketing so when we
mean by digital marketing we mean
advertising to people via different
channels and so we're going to hone in
on digital marketing and look at what
those opportunities are so let's talk a
little bit about digital marketing so
digital marketing really involves
selling a product or service using
several different online sdigital
marketing channels so some of the most
popular dig digital marketing channels
used by a lot of companies today is SEO
which is search engine optimization sem
which is search engine marketing that's
paid search so if you see a sponsored ad
on Google that would be related to sem
most of you probably already familiar
with email marketing meaning you
probably received an email from a
company trying to promote or sell a
product or service so those are some of
the most popular channels of course
there's other channels like video
social affiliate influencer marketing
display so there's a lot of different
marketing channels that fall under the
umbrella of digital marketing and so
those are some of the online marketing
channels used by companies to promote
their products and services and so in a
sense that's what digital marketing is
and so because digital marketing is
involves a lot of channels a lot of
companies need people to you know work
on those channels for that company
promoting that product or services so
let's take a look at some of those
particular roles involved with digital
marketing and the first one really is a
digital marketing manager so that's
overseeing all these different marketing
channels okay so somebody looking and
managing these different marketing
channels we just mentioned like SEO SL
organic search or paid search or social
okay so digital marketing managers over
see and Implement these different
campaigns across different channels with
the strategy of either brand awareness
or selling a particular product or
promoting the company's services and so
with a digital marketing manager it's a
broad title in a sense but it comes with
a lot of responsibilities so if we look
at some of these responsibilities it's
really designing and overseeing all the
aspects of digital marketing when we say
all aspects we don't mean just campaigns
but really what we mean is managing a
marketing database if you're
implementing campaigns and you're
collecting information as a result you
want to be able to store and manage that
information appropriately it also comes
down to being able and being familiar
and being fluent in different marketing
channels like jumping from email
marketing to display marketing when you
manage multiple campaigns and channels
you have to have a budget so you got to
be able to develop and maintain a budget
so being a digital marketing manager
means you know being able to articulate
and respond to channels that are working
and assigning budget accordingly based
on performance and not only just
assigning budget but making sure the
budget gets implemented appropriately
social is a big part of digital
marketing and so in itself that's an 800
lb gorilla meaning it's a lot of
responsibility so plan and manage social
media platforms you know for a lot of
companies they're quick to jump out
there on the deep end when it comes to
social so a digital marketing manager
really is someone who can reel that in
and say you know what look we don't need
to be on Twitter or LinkedIn you know
having that responsibility taking the
responsibility for managing the social
media platforms accordingly one of the
biggest jobs of a digital marketing
manager in my opinion is maintaining
reports and it's not even maintaining
reports I mean a lot of tools like
Google analytics will create the report
for you we talk about maintaining
reports we really mean looking at those
reports looking at the performance of
these campaigns and channels and
reacting accordingly and that leads to
the next bullet point really with the
digital marketing manager and that means
coming up with new growth strategies
because if let's just say a paid search
campaign is really performing okay how
are we going to grow that strategy how
are we going to grow that campaign vice
versa if your Facebook ads aren't
performing what can we do to get them to
grow and perform so that's the job of a
digital marketing manager react
according to the performance of
campaigns and continue to grow and build
out the campaigns and channels and then
with that comes you know some side
projects and some issues that need to be
resolved and so a good digital marketing
manager has their pulse on everything
related to that particular digital
marketing channel for example a website
okay if the website's getting rebuilt or
moving to a new platform or being
redesigned digital marketing manager
needs to be part of that project and
needs to be able to help manage that
project alongside the channels and
campaigns he or she is responsible for
so as you can see a lot of
responsibility with a digital marketing
manager so with that responsibility
comes experience
and so to jump into the deep end I'm
becoming a digital marketing manager in
my opinion you need to have some
experience maybe not across all channels
but at the very least some of the most
important channels we talked about
already SEO sem email social uh email's
been around a long time SEO is just so
key it's it's the biggest marketing
channel out there you paid search is
very fast and dynamic involves a lot of
budget and management so you need
someone with experience and you know
someone with at least 5 years experience
in digital marketing or advertising can
fit the role of course there's always
going to be growth this is digital
marketing it's still young if you
compare digital marketing against
traditional platforms like TV or radio
or print we're only talking about 15 to
20 years of experience for digital
marketing out there as an advertising
plat platform so having 5 years out of
20 years of existence is not too bad now
with that comes a degree of some sort
with marketing okay so you need to have
at least a bachelor's a master's degree
really goes far because usually those
that contain a master's degree usually
has have an MBA or Master's of Business
Administration and to me that's a nice
compliment to having a nice set of
experience in digital marketing and so
it's also a plus to really have some
knowledge about social media okay some
of the best practices uh that go with
social media some of the analytics that
go with social media and not just social
media but in general too so what are
some digital marketing best practices
that you with your experience can apply
what's your knowledge of websites do you
have any programming experience do you
have any design experience do you have
any we we analytics experience okay
having those skill sets meaning
understanding HTML or css or JavaScript
or being able to articulate how a
website's performing in Google analytics
definitely complement the role of a
digital marketing manager and in most
cases is part of the role of a digital
marketing manager and then one of the
biggest skills required and I think
every company looks for this
communication and interpersonal skills
so you have to be able to communicate
with your colleagues with your
stakeholders with your clients with your
contractors with anybody else supporting
your efforts or the efforts you're
supporting for somebody else so
communication is key and today's world
there's a lot of communication tools out
there I mean you have traditional email
you have text messaging you have nice
tools out there like a and slack to help
you know solidify the way communication
is streamlined and so you have to be
able to stay on top of communication
because you're going to be reporting up
and you're going to be reporting down to
you know those that are part of your
efforts and then a real big big bonus is
up todate with Trends and Technologies
and digital marketing so stay in the
know stay in the know attend conferences
attend webinars attending this webinar
definitely helps your positioning so
stay up to date and what I usually tell
you know other students of mine is hey
you know sign up for two or three
sources out there on the internet it
could be for example Google's web Master
blog or Google analytics video or
YouTube channel or you need subscribe to
Website Magazine or you know get an
email subscription to search engine land
there's hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of resources out there on the
internet there's no excuse not to stay
up to dat and then one thing that's not
listed here that I would highly
recommend is have a Blog having a Blog
offers up multiple advantages one it
promotes you as a brand okay two
whatever your blogging about and in this
case it could be something general like
digital marketing or could be a specific
Channel like SEO or could be
analytically driven meaning you know
numbers and everything related to
digital marketing when it comes to
analytics whatever your Niche is you
know write about it because it puts you
in a good position that one you're up to
date with the trends again you're
promoting your brand and two it shows
off your communication style so having a
Blog whether you keep it updated once a
month twice a month four times a month
goes a long way versus not having a Blog
at all because it shows you're
enthusiastic about the industry and the
job profession of digital marketing and
it really puts you in a good spot so
that's my recommendation there in
addition to all the skills required for
this position and you know salary you
know it depends it depends on experience
it depends on the company I mean if you
go with a nonprofit versus a for
for-profit company the pay might be
lower it depends on the company you
could go with a startup versus a more
traditional company and it's a startup
they may pay more it really depends on
the company it really depends on the
industry the organization the experience
that you have the skill sets you bring
to the table all of that plays a role so
the salaries listed here are really just
averages really it's averages because if
you look at
73,000 annually in the US okay if you're
you know get a nice digital marketing
job and say Kansas 73,000 is a lot of
money well it's all relevant because if
you go to California and San Francisco
73,000 is not even the medium salary for
somebody who lives in San Francisco so
it is contingent also on location so
what you need to do when it comes to
salary is take a look at your own
experience take a look at what you've
been paid previously if you have 5 years
experience and you're making 50,000 and
you feel you've done a good job and
you've earned the skill sets and the
experience needed for the new position
you're applying for then there's no
reason why you can't ask for more money
than say the average okay so really a
lot of things are contingent on salary
but the one thing you can do to control
salary is make sure your skill sets are
in line with the job required so let's
move on to content strategist and you
know content strategist it's just a
title that we're using for this webinar
I there's a lot of job titles out there
the key thing here with a Content
strategist is somebody who's involving
themselves with with content so they're
developing content okay so you can call
it a Content writer a copywriter a
strategist the devel content
developer the king of content the queen
of content it doesn't really matter what
the title is when you see the word
content you know that your job is to
develop content that caters to the
company's objectives and so with a lot
of digital marketing channels out there
today okay content strategist are high
demand very high demand so some of the
responsibilities that go with a Content
strategist is you want to be able to
manage the editorial calendar to ensure
timely publication and what do I mean by
that well as a Content strategist you
could be asked to write social post
supporting a social media manager okay
so you want to be able to come up with a
calendar of sorts to be able to post at
a specific point in time that that's
going to ensure High engagement so
having some sense of time definitely
goes along with the job okay you want to
identify gaps and content recommend new
topics so for example a Blog if you're
responsible for generating content for
the company's blog you probably want to
take a look at the categories and the
topics that have already been written
about and you want to be able to
identify new areas of content and that's
just an example but you want to do that
across all channels okay you want to be
able to create brand style guide if a
brand doesn't have a style guide already
that's a place where you can really
shine okay because a brand needs to have
a certain tone a certain message a
certain point of view okay it needs to
stand for something and a good content
strategist is one who can help create it
help implement it help enforce it okay
so brand styling goes a long way with
the job okay being able to not only
write perect read and edit pieces before
publishing them goes a long way too you
know some of the best content
strategists I've ever come across are
ones that ask me or colleague to
proofread their own content okay so you
know a good content strategist is one
that looks outward to make sure that the
copy or the content they're producing is
up to Snuff it's aligned with the brand
it's articulate and is centered and
geared towards the the intended target
audience so having somebody else proof
free to me says something about a
Content strategist and vice versa being
able to proof forre somebody else's work
to make sure yes what they're writing is
good solid grammatically written up the
brand intended for the right target
audience I mean so that's part of the
job being able to proof read and editing
okay another responsibility with a
Content strategist is identifying
content topics based on keyword research
and this aligns with with search okay so
with search engine optimization it's all
about keywords and you need to be able
to identify the content that goes along
with those keywords okay we talk about
this in depth on some of our other SEO
webinars and I'll mention those in a
couple minutes but being able to
identify the content that aligns with
those keywords is really part of an SEO
strategy and to me this next bullet
point really goes a long way you want to
be able to monitor web travel trff and
engagement because if you're responsible
for the website if you're responsible
for producing content on a particular
website you want to see how that
content's performing so just because
you're a Content strategist doesn't mean
necessarily you're not immune to looking
at data you are you everybody has a role
when it comes to the website everybody
should take a look at data and react
accordingly to the data including those
who produce content and then you want to
be able to coordinate with stakehold
olders in the organization because the
stakeholders are the one who ones who
are going to have some say in what
content so just like a digital marketing
manager to me another piece of
responsibility is for the content
strategist to be able to communicate
with the stakeholders let them know hey
this is the content that's going out
this is our editorial calendar hey let
me proofread some of your content hey
this is the brand style okay so the
content strategist really is somebody
who's Center in terms of of all content
that's developed for a particular
organization now some of the skills
required to me you know you can have a
nice marketing degree or journalism or
literature anything that's going to have
some background in writing some
experience as a Content strategist or
manager in a similar role so you could
be a Blog Ambassador for another brand
and fill the role of a Content
strategist you can be an influencer and
and be somebody who really influences
different companies and industries that
job would be able to fit a Content
strategist because most influencers
write or produce content See I having a
basic understanding of HTML and web
publishing so you want to be able to
understand how the web works you know
you want to be able to understand what
it takes to create a web page because
every web page has content you need to
have experience with SEO and you need to
have experience with keyword research
tools because to me a Content strategist
is the one who drives this part of the
SEO process to me the content strategist
looks at data when it comes to keyword
analysis is able to apply pick and
choose keywords to align with content
and then write content not just write
content but optimize the content for SEO
and then experience with social media
and not only just social media but the
different platforms out there when I
talk about understanding social media
for business and the different platforms
that can help a business thrive in that
channel you need to understand you know
the tended audiences that go to that
platform you need to understand the
formatting and the opportunities for
writing the content on that platform you
know anybody can you know stroke a
keyboard and put words on a screen or
break out a pen and put words on paper
but it really takes someone with you
know really fine experience to really
know who they're writing for what
platform they're writing for and the
guidelines and the regulations that go
along with writing that content so to me
that separates out a good content
strategist from an average content
strategist and of course excellent
writing and editing skills go a long way
that comes with experience in my opinion
but what you could do if you lack
experience in editing is volunteer for
nonprofit most nonprofits have blogs
volunteer to write a blog post for the
nonprofit or if you don't even want to
go that route like a digital marketing
manager have your own blog if you have a
passion for food or passion for travel
or passion for animals or pets or dogs
write about it that's what's going to
give you the experience and writing
editing and it shows hey look you're
enthusiastic about something and it show
shows your brand and your tone so like a
digital marketing manager having a Blog
goes a long way if you don't have your
own blog then be able to gain the
experience necessary in writing and
editing by doing it for others even if
it means pro bono volunteer so salary
just like a digital marketing manager
commencement on a lot of factors
experience location
organization you know the department of
the organiz ation the type of
organization the industry I mean like I
said with the digital marketing manager
position hey if you're at a startup you
and you're applying for a Content
strategist role chances are you're
probably going to ask for more money
than the average because you're probably
going to be writing content not only for
the website or the blog not only for
social but it could be some offline
opportunity as well meaning press
releases brochures TV ad spots radio
spots so you got to be open as a Content
strategist especially when you're
working in a startup because you're
likely going to wear many hats now if
you're applying for a traditional job at
a company that's been around a long time
then your job may be really focused and
honed in on a specific you know role so
keep that in mind as well so these
salaries are average so a lot of factors
are involved so let's go into SEO so an
SEO specialist so could be an SEO pundit
an SEO expert somebody who's really
familiar with the role and the channel
of SEO so to me SEO is a big Channel a
lot of responsibility so SCS Specialists
are responsible for analyzing reviewing
implementing not just changes to the
website but things that happen off the
website because with seo seo is built
into two branches or two strategies off
page and on page okay so being an SEO
specialist you got to be able to hone in
on what to do on your own website for
onpage SEO but you got to be able to be
Savvy enough to put together an off page
strategy and not only that you got to be
techically Savvy because a lot of what
goes in SEO involves some techical
aspects like 44 or page load or sit Maps
or css or for you know accelerated
mobile Pages mobile usability structured
Snippets featured Snippets all of these
are factors that are related to SEO so
an SEO specialist is somebody who really
is able to juggle both the website from
a technical standpoint onpage
optimization and off-page optimization
it's a big role and so therefore if we
break down the responsibilities again
it's reviewing and analyzing the site
from Improvement and optimization in
other words somebody needs to be Savvy
enough if they're called an SCS
specialist to be able to conduct an
audit for an SEO strategy and be able to
identify areas of improvement so
preparing strategy reports so what does
that mean well that can mean a lot of
things so when we talk about strategy
and reports you need to be Savvy enough
to create a keyword analysis okay you
need to be Savvy enough to be able to
assign keywords you need to be Savvy
enough enough to even know how to
optimize a page yes you may have a
Content strategist do that work but as
an SE specialist you need to be able to
know how to do that as well okay you
need to be able to identify keywords
okay in a keyword anales just like a
Content strategist you need to be able
to assign keywords and you need to be
able to write effective SEO content not
only for the blog or website and social
media but it could be across other
different channels as well so being part
of the content is part of being an SEO
specialist because if you work at a
startup you may not have a quote unquote
content strategist to support you so you
may have to do everything you may have
to you know not only audit the site you
may not only have to address some of the
website needs from a technical
standpoint but you may have to do the
keyword analysis the keyword assignments
and optimize the content for SEO and
then take it to off-page you may have to
write the content for off-page SEO
meaning social or it could be on other
platforms like Wikipedia medium Reddit
Kora okay so all of these platforms
require content that are part of an SEO
strategy so being able to you know
prepare a strategy being able to
identify keywords via keyword analysis
being able to write content that
supports your SEO strategy or all part
of the responsibilities of an SEO
specialist and again part of that
strategy because it's on page and off
page is you need to be able to put
together an off page SEO strategy and
that's going to again involve content so
before you start writing content for
various platforms you need to be able to
put in a sound strategy what platforms
are we going to go after you know what
are the domain and Page authority of
those platforms how much content do we
need to write how often the frequency
what type of content are we going to
write all of that's part of a link
building off-page SEO strategy and to me
one of the biggest responsibilities of
an SEO specialist is being able to not
only analyze keywords and SEO techniques
used by your competitors but just being
able to analyze and measure SEO overall
yes you need to be able to look at what
your competitors are doing but you need
to be able to for example leverage an SE
o platform look at that SEO platform
understand how your overall SEO efforts
are performing and continue to make
adjustments so that's an SEO specialist
wrapped up and if we look at some of the
skills you know you need to have some
SEO experience not having SEO experience
and applying for an SEO job is really
selling yourself short because SEO
involves some tactical aspects some
creative aspects and some good sound
strategy y along with a lot of analytics
so you need to be familiar with
analytics tools and other tools that
going to measure the performance of your
SEO strategy so you need to be able to
familiarize yourself with some of the
SEO platforms that are out there like MZ
or sem rush because they produce
analytic data as well meaning ranking
information or domain and Page Authority
you need to be able to understand what
those metrics are and how to react to
them you need to be able to understand
Google analytics from an organic search
perspective you know what are some of
the kpis you're aligning with Organic
search how you measuring organic search
behavior from an engagement standpoint
or from a conversion standpoint and
because SEO has a technical aspect to it
you need to be able to understand you
know the web platform that you're on is
it WordPress okay how do plugins work do
I have all my plugins what theme am I
using you know what's the CSS s of that
theme so you need to be able to
understand all the elements of your
website that are going to affect SEO and
so with that you need to stay in the no
you need to understand all the different
ranking factors and how these different
search engines run in terms of their
algorithms you know the pundit say there
are 200 plus different factors that
affect Google's ranking algorithm so
what are those 200 ranking factors do
you have a certain knowledge set of how
search works okay do you know how the
Bots work okay do you know the best
practices for sitemap okay so these are
all the things you need to know and all
the skills you need to obtain to be an
SEO specialist and just like every
position we're going to cover and we've
covered already you need to stay up to
date with the latest trends and
practices because SEO changes frequently
Google changes their algorithms and they
change their algorithms without not even
letting you know so you need to stay up
to dat with what Google's doing okay or
some of the other search engines and so
there's a lot of different resources
available you need to be Savvy enough to
pick and choose the resources that are
going to keep you up to date you need to
know you know how search console works I
mean there's just a lot of different
factors involved with SEO it's a very
well-rounded Channel with a lot of
responsibility so you know if you don't
have the experience necessary well in my
opinion you can come in easily as a
Content strategist you can't come in as
a web developer and be an SEO specialist
because you're going to have some
working knowledge of you know how a
website works or how social or off-page
SEO works but an SEO specialist is one
who puts it all together and so to me
you know salary again these are just
averages and they do vary okay whether
you're in India USA Europe other parts
of Asia South America you know salary is
going to be contingent on location it's
going to be contingent on your
experience and the one thing here to
prove your experience and to prove your
worth in terms of salary is to be able
to show what you've done in the past in
terms of progress for another client or
another website so you need to be able
to be able to show you know those who
you're looking to work for here's what
I've done in the past here's the
methodology here are the metrics I use
to measure here are some of the results
of that effort okay so you need to be
able to show you know some case studies
best practices and historical
performance and to me if you could show
that then you're worth every bit of the
salary that that particular company
would offer up so let's move on to sem
specialist so SEO specialist a lot of
factors involved there off page on page
semm is search but it's a whole
different set of skills versus SEO a
whole different skill set and why
because an sem specialist it could be an
sem manager or whatever again you want
to call it but the channel here is sem
search engine marketing and really
somebody who's part of sem is going to
be able to manage paid search campaigns
across multiple channels across multiple
networks okay so it may not even be just
a search Network it could be the Display
Network okay so you need to know how
Google and Yahoo and Bing and bu and
Linkedin and Twitter all these paid
search platforms you need to know how
they work and be able to manage
campaigns effectively on those platforms
so some of the some of the
responsibilities now I will say this
with an S with sem it's very fast paid
so you need your responsibility is to
keep up with campaign performance and
some of the things you're going to do
some of the responsibilities you're
going to conduct while being by managing
campaigns are going to be testing a lot
of testing and a lot of analyzing data
okay so you need to be able to react to
the data you see okay so you need to
identify Trends to achieve maximum
return on investment so in my opinion
a good sem specialist is one who
identifies their kpis beforehand and
then identifies the strategy beforehand
and then being able to execute that
strategy and then after executing that
strategy being able to optimize the
campaign so you're able to achieve
maximum performance and maximum results
that's really the job of an semm
specialist so you need to be able to
execute according to strategy you need
to be able to track and report on the
performance and not just track and
report but you need to be able to react
because with payperclick or cost per
click or sponsored search or search
engine marketing whatever you want to
call it it's going to be fast-paced
meaning you're going to get data and
you're going to get data very quickly
and so you have to be good at looking at
numbers and reacting to those numbers
and another major responsibility is
being a able to manage a budget if a
client gives you money you need to be
able to manage that budget accordingly
first things first you need to be able
to plot a strategy that's going to spend
that budget wisely and you need to be
able to Monitor and maintain that budget
you don't overspend the budget and not
only just overspend the budget but UND
spend the budget so if a client hands
you $1,000 don't spend 500 of it don't
spend 1,500 of it spend ,000
look at the results along the way and
come back to the client and tell them
hey here's the maximum results for that
$1,000 and here's what I recommend
moving forward based on the work and the
optimization we've done that's part of
being an sem specialist is being able to
manage and maintain the budget maximize
your efforts for those paid search
campaigns while you're spending that
budget and some of the other
responsibilities with an sem specialist
is not just managing numbers and data
it's being able to write ad copy and not
only write ad copy but know the
different guidelines and formats of
these different paid campaigns and
platforms because the guidelines for
Google are going to be different from
the guidelines on Facebook and so you
need to be able to also react to that ad
copy according to the platform and not
only the ad copy but the landing pages
as well you need to be able and be Savvy
and technically Savvy enough to be able
to set up unique landing pages for your
pay-per-click campaigns okay that's part
of an semm specialist leading the way on
creating landing pages and not just
creating landing pages but also doing AB
testing on those landing pages a good
sdn specialist with experience is going
to be able to raise their hand and say
look this landing page is not performing
let's put an AV test in place so that we
can improve performance of our paid
search campaign so one of the ultimate
jobs of an sem specialist is always
always looking at keywords being able to
identify keywords that are performing
you know being Savvy enough to pause the
keywords that are not performing being
able to optimize keywords to gain better
performance and to expand the keyword
list whether that being in a different
campaign or ad group or you know adset
so identifying and managing keywords is
probably the number one job of an SCM
specialist because keywords are what
drive a lot of paid search especially on
Google Yahoo and Bing so a lot of
responsibility with an sem specialist
you're giving the
responsibility of running a campaign
against a budget and you have to move at
a fast pace so it's not an easy role
it's not for the fainted heart you need
to be able to react to data at a very
fastpac and so what are some of the
skills required for a job like this well
you need to have experience with search
engine Marketing in general but it would
help to have experience across multiple
platforms I would even go as far as not
just saying Yahoo and Bing and Google
but Facebook LinkedIn ad roll and not
only just Google search but you need to
be able to show that you can manage paid
search campaigns across Google's Display
Network meaning display play banners and
even video campaigns on YouTube or
remarketing campaigns or shopping ad
campaigns so you need to have a
well-rounded View and well-rounded
experience on how search works and all
the different types of campaigns you can
run on a search platform you need to be
well-versed in metrics paid search is
about reacting to data and performing
The Campaign at the maximum so if you're
managing a campaign for an e-commerce
website what are your kpis what's your
cost per acquisition you know if I'm
selling a t-shirt for $2 do I want my
cost per acquisition to be $25 no so you
need to be able to understand the
different metrics and the different kpis
aligned with a specific strategy or
website or business and you need to
manage against those metrics whether
that be cost per acquisition or
conversion rate or raw conversions you
need to be staying up to date with the
latest sem Trends because paid search
especially on Google they come out with
a lot of features and updates all the
time and you need to be able to know
what those updates are so you could take
advantage of them do you know that you
know Google offers up responsive ads
okay do you know that they have
different ad extensions for say mobile
or location okay you need to stay up to
dat with all the features on every
platform so you can maximize those
features for your clients again you need
to have strong analytical skills you
know if you're not good with numbers
then being an sem specialist is probably
not for you being comfortable with
numbers and being able to react to those
numbers that's a sign of a good strong
analytical skill set now sem involves a
lot of testing because AB testing and
payperclick go together because
payperclick is a controlled environment
so are doing AB testing and being able
to identify AB testing not just for
landing pages but for ad copy so you
need to be able to be familiar with how
AB testing works and being comfortable
you know identifying areas that need AB
testing crumming up with variations
coming up with those kpis and then
having a well-rounded knowledge of how a
website works never hurts because you
may be tasked with setting up the AB
test for landing page so to me you know
being an STM specialist it's a cool cool
job I particularly like paperclick it's
very fastpaced you get to react you get
to do a lot of different things here um
across different platforms and to see
the fruits of your labor pay off for the
client meaning good campaign performance
is well worth the reward of being an SDM
specialist and again you know we're
looking at 65,000 in the US and that's
contingent on experience and to me I
would probably go as far as saying you
know you need to have at least 5 years
experience as an sem specialist and you
need to be able to show a well-rounded
view of what you've managed in the past
so whether that be paid search campaigns
on Google search display video shopping
remarketing you know social paid ads on
different platforms like LinkedIn
Twitter Facebook you know you could even
do paid search on other platforms or
websites as well and even understanding
you know how AdSense works you know the
other way around how a publisher gets
money because that's part of the Display
Network so looking at it not from an
Advertiser point of view but from a
publisher standpoint so showing a
well-rounded knowledge of how paid
search works really goes a long way into
how much you actually make as an
specialist let's move over to social
media marketer so social media social
media marketers are in high demand
because a lot of companies are on social
media so social media marketers achieve
customer engagement intimacy they want
to drive website traffic they want to
convert that traffic to revenue okay so
they want to take advantage of all the
features available on that particular
social media platform and so some of the
responsibilities involved with being a
social media marketer involves you know
building and executing a strategy on
that particular social media St uh
platform so you want to be able to look
at what your competitors are doing you
want to put in a good strategy and when
I say a good strategy that means
identifying what platforms identifying
the messaging okay is it going to be
brand or SEO based or sales based okay
being able to build build an audience on
that platform knowing who your target
audience is okay that's first and
foremost from a social media perspective
a good social media marketer needs to
know what they're getting themselves
involved with before they execute okay
and then once you are able to plan and
strategize then comes the work you need
to be able to generate edit publish and
share content and the whole point here
is it's based on strategy so is it brand
awareness is it Community Building at
the end of the day you're going to want
to see some type of Engagement or you're
going to want to be able to see
something in return for the content
you're posting so are you in for likes
or are you in for shares or are you in
for website traffic or are you in for
conversions okay so you need to be able
to manage that based on the content you
published and so to me when you're
talking about content and you're talking
about social media you you need to be
able to lean on a good social media
platform there are plenty out there like
buffer or or Sprout social or hoot site
or later there are plenty of social
media platforms out there and you need
to familiarize yourself and be able to
leverage that social media platform to
manage your content manage the data
you're seeing from the social media
platforms and then basically the whole
idea behind social is it's based on a
strategy so you need to be able to
improve that strategy by analyzing those
metrics insights and understand some of
the best practices in order to improve
so it's a very broad sense of
responsibilities because it does depend
on the platform it does depend on the
business it does depend on your strategy
you could just be responsible for
Twitter okay so Twitter has you know
very limited number of characters
involved with cont content but just
because there's not a lot of content
doesn't mean the strategy isn't as
intense as it would be on Facebook or
LinkedIn so you need to be able to
adjust and adapt to the platform you're
working on and so to me some of the
skills required you know it helps to
have an NBA but I think it definitely
does help to have experience as a social
media marketer you know two years is
probably good enough experience but in
my opinion the more experience you have
and the more experience you have across
multitude of platforms definitely says
something about your skill set so it
needs a crossover as well it needs a
cross over that skill set needs a cross
over into different marketing channels
for example paid search why because you
could be asked to write content for paid
ads on Facebook it needs to be able to
cross over an SEO why because you could
be asked to write content for off-page
SEO on a particular social media
platform and needs to be able to cross
over and the say email because you could
be contributing to that email newsletter
that goes out that's pulling Snippets of
content from your social work so you
need to familiarize yourself with how
different marketing channels work
because they overlap with social media
and then just like a Content strategist
just like SEO sem a digital marketing
manager you need to be able and be
comfortable going into Google analytics
through your analytics platform you need
need to be able to identify social as a
channel and be able to measure how that
particular channel is working and not
only how it's working in terms of your
kpis which could be engagement or
conversion based but you need to be
Savvy enough to react to the data let's
just say you're not driving enough
traffic from Facebook and Facebook is
your primary social media platform what
are you going to do how are you going to
adjust that strategy to drive more
traffic so that's a good Savvy social
media marketer somebody who's able to go
into an analytics platform and react to
the data they're seeing based on the
strategy that they're trying to
implement and then you know having
well-rounded experience with all the
different social networking and social
analytics tools definitely shows your
experience if you have one experience a
little experience with just one platform
like Sprout social then get experience
jump into hoot weet or buff or or some
of these other platforms and know the
differences between them because
basically one social media platform may
not work for one company you may have to
lean on one or two based on the features
that they offer and you need to be Savvy
enough to identify that so that you can
assist the organization you're working
for so that to me shows a lot of
maturity and experience knowing where to
go to maximize your efforts so social
media marketers they're in abundance but
they're in need okay so you can really
Niche yourself a good career whether
that be at a startup or whether it be at
a traditional company whether it be in a
nonprofit or for-profit whether that be
in Tech or real estate or law or medical
or Insurance it doesn't matter social
media marketers are in need but a good
social media marketer are those that
take into account the skills we talked
about he let's turn our attention to
email marketing so let's take a look at
email marketing here so email
marketing's been around a long time so
email marketing specialist if you will
are those that Pro promote the organ
organizations product or Services via
email so the aim is to really get those
emails to work so email marketing's been
around most people today have email
addresses are familiar with email
marketing because most organizations use
email marketing as a digital marketing
channel and so a good email marketing
specialist is responsible for the design
and the
implementation of an email marketing
campaign and so to me they need to be
able to also identify the platform that
they're going to be working with so if
you're going to implement an email
marketing campaign you need to be able
to identify the platform that you're
going to work work in and there are
plenty of email marketing platforms and
there are plenty of marketing automation
tools that offer up email as a feature
so you need to be able to identify not
only a marketing automation platform
that works with your email marketing
strategy but a good email marketing
platform you know there's vertical
response there's mail champ there's you
know a lot of different marketing plat
email marketing platforms out there so
try and test a few of them and
understand how they work just like
social media there's an abundance of
email marketing platforms so you need to
be able to identify one that's going to
align with your strategy and give you
all the features and benefits available
and you need to be able to identify your
target audience because you're not going
to send one email to your entire
audience list you're going to need to be
able to dissect that entire audience
list into different segments and that's
what a good email marketing specialist
does identify different segments of
audience you need to be just like a
Content strategist able to proofread
copy in some cases you may be writing
that copy for the email if you work at a
startup and you don't have a Content
strategist maybe you are a Content
strategist who's also assigned as an
email marketing specialist either way
you need to be able to look at the copy
that's in that email and ask yourself
you know is this copy intended for a
target audience does it fit our brand
guidelines does it fit our brand
messaging do the call to actions fit
what we're trying to achieve you know
all that's part of an email marketing
specialist an email marketing specialist
needs a good set of eyes and you need to
understand the technical aspects of
email because no longer are we sending
email to somebody on a computer on a
desktop who's downloading that email
onto say some software program like
Outlook not today today most people are
looking at email on the fly on the go
Via Mobile so we need to make sure that
emails you know fit our audience across
multiple devices so you need to be able
to ensure that you know your emails are
mobile friendly cuz most people are
looking at emails on their mobile phones
and and timing is everything with email
metrics just like any other channel is
important with email so you need to know
when you're going to be able to send
that email what time of day you're going
to be able to send that email and you
need to understand the campaign
performance why so that you can respond
and optimize the email marketing efforts
moving forward and then another
responsibility not really listed here
but it does go with the job and that's
AB testing so just like an sem
specialist you need to be able to
understand how AB testing works why
because you may not just be optimizing
laning Pages for an AB test you may be
looking at an AB test for subject lines
in fact a good email marketing
specialist never sends out an email
without AB testing the subject line and
so you need to be familiar with how AB
testing works because that goes along
with improving campaign performance and
knowing industry policies and best
practices especially with email goes a
long way because there are a lot of
regulations involved around you know
email and it does come down to also the
industry what you could say and what you
can't say by industry does factor in so
staying up to date with industry
policies and best practices definitely
is part of the responsibility of an
email marketing specialist now skills
required should have experience with
email marketing and to me I would take
this a step further you know having
well-rounded experience working for a
startup working for a larger company and
working for a company that has different
Target audiences meaning segmented
audiences you can show that hey I know
how to send out an email to a large
number of people and they could be
subsets of a bigger audience and you
need to be able to show you know the
different styles and the different
platforms uh for email marketing that
you've worked with and a lot of email
requires HTML or knowledge of HTML so
you're going to have to know HTML
because you may have to edit HTML you
need to know how UTM tracking works okay
urgent tracking module so if you don't
know what UTM tracking is and you want
to be an email marketing specialist you
need to know what that is and get some
hands-on experience using UTM tracking
because you need to track emails and if
you're using Google analytics as your
analytics platform then you definitely
will need UTM tracking because you need
to be able to be comfortable to go into
Google analytics and look at your email
campaign performance does it align with
your kpis and you need to be able to
have some project management skills
because a lot goes into email marketing
you know it's the design of it it's the
timing of it it's the copy it's the AB
testing it's the analytical part if
you're working for a big company that
has 35 different Target audiences you
could be sending out multiple emails on
a daily basis for different audiences
and so you need to be able to project
manage each of these email campaigns and
so those are the skills required for an
email marketing specialist and again
salary contingent upon experience the
more experience you have as an email
Market marketer the more you're going to
make and experience to me is based on
you know how many email marketing
platforms you work with how many
companies have you done email marketing
for how well-rounded have your emails
been how many Target audiences how big
have those target audience has been do
you understand the concept of analytics
and the concept of AB testing so if you
do and you checked off all those boxes
then you can command more than what the
average is for an email marketing
specialist so let's take a look at a
digital marketing resume so my
recommendation and this is just my
opinion would be to build your resume
off a platform like LinkedIn so if
you're not on LinkedIn then I would
definitely recommend you get on LinkedIn
and if you're going to be a social media
marketer then you definitely should be
on LinkedIn if you're going to be a
Content Strater even digital marketing
manager you need to be on LinkedIn
LinkedIn is a businesso business
platform so it allows you to put your
best foot forward in front of a lot of
people so not only those you connect
with but there's a lot of recruiters who
work on LinkedIn and these recruiters
are looking for people with experience
who fit the job they're trying to fill
and so to me if we look at a good resume
you know especially on LinkedIn LinkedIn
allows you to have a plat platform to
put in all your experience and so you
know depending on what you're trying to
go for I would Niche towards that so if
you're going to be a digital marketing
manager then you could see in this
example two years experience with
content SEO marketing automation email
sem and market research those are part
of the skill sets required for digital
marketing manager so you want to put in
a summary a good summary to include how
much experience you have and anything
that supports your claim to be a digital
marketing manager or an email marketing
manager or social media marketing
manager that's part of the summary and
then you want to put your experience in
there and to me putting your experience
in there is key I would include all your
experience everything you've ever done
geared towards the job you're going for
and to me one thing about experience is
when you write out your experience put
in what your responsibility were and
then I think what's key here in this
example you could see this person had
associate digital marketing manager
experience for one year and what they
did was they actually showed the
improvements they made as a digital
marketing manager so you can see
increased organic page views 30% with a
reduction of bounce rates on websites
through site content management and semm
Analysis so they actually put some Quant
itative data in there to show that hey
this is what I've done and this is what
I've done to improve this particular
company's uh website and so to me it's
action oriented it shows some
quantitative analysis it shows you've
actually done work that made Improvement
and it also shows that you have command
of analytics because every job under the
digital marketing realm involves
quantitative and analytical data and so
putting analytical data and your resume
shows that you know what you're talking
about so here you could see on the next
example hey as a marketing intern for
Nike you one good year here's all the
tools I've worked with so to me that's
also a plus you want to show again a lot
of these positions require knowledge of
some of the most common platforms okay
whether that an analytical platform an
email marketing platform an o platform
or social media platform if you worked
in that platform put it down it shows
that you're well-rounded and so that's a
good suggestion to show hey you have
experience working with these platforms
and hey you have command of analytics
obviously putting your education down
there you know to me I'm not a recruiter
I don't think CPA is such a big deal to
me experience is more of a big deal and
then you definitely to support that
experience to show that you're in the no
to show that you stay up to date that
show that you're up to date with the
latest trends and best practices I would
definitely put your certifications and
so if you're trying to be an sem
Specialist or strategist then make sure
you have Google ads certifications and
not just Google ads but all facets of
Google ads and what Google ads has to
offer get your certification in Mobile
get your certification in video get it
in shopping get it in display put those
certifications down there because it
shows you're well-rounded and regardless
of what position you're going for
whether it be content or email go for
the Google analytics certification all
these certifications I mentioned by
Google are free Bing has certifications
Facebook has certifications get those
certifications and put them down there
because again it shows that you're in
command of your your career it shows
that you're up to date with the latest
and greatest it shows that you know what
you're talking about because you've
taken the initiative to get a
certification so to me these are all the
key ingredients to a good resume you
know Niche it to what you're trying to
do write a good summary that supports
your effort you know put your experience
down there but when you put your
experience support it with quantitative
measurements and metrics put down all
the experience you have with platforms
you know put some other elements in
there that are intangibles like
communication you know show that you
know how to communicate hey we use slack
to communicate to a team of 100 across
five different countries as an example
because it shows that you have a grasp
of what it takes to communicate with a
team at large of course put your
education but more importantly get those
certifications put them down there
because it shows you know what you're
doing you're walking the walk not just
talking the talk so if you're interested
in a career in digital marketing and you
don't have the necessary experience and
say Google analytics then take a look at
our Google analytics tutorial for
beginners you know looking over the
webinar give you some more insight into
Google analytics and Propel you into
maybe taking the certification likewise
we have one for email marketing if
you're interested in being an email
marketer you know take a look at our
webinar on email marketing and then SEO
if you don't have the necessary
experience and you're not sure of
everything involved in SEO then take a
look at SEO tutorial for beginners so we
have a lot more webinars available at
simply learn so if you're lacking in one
area the other you know go to our
Channel on YouTube to fill in the gaps
of what you need to enhance your career
so search engine of optimization
or organic search we have a mixture of
paid and free so there's a lot of
different platforms but if you're
focusing on SEO you certainly need to
use an SEO platform so there's sem Rush
okay you also have Google search console
which is free so if you don't have a SEO
platform you definitely need to be using
Google search console and so we'll take
a closer look at that there's Google
Keyword Planner which is actually
situated on under Google ads and so if
you're running Google campaigns on
Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called keyboard planner and
if you know anything about SEO you'll
know that using Google's Keyword Planner
is a good tool so we'll take a look at
that MZ is a premium tool meaning they
have a free trial that you can sign up
for to test drive it but it's another
SEO platform and it does cost money got
a great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in HRS
that help us with all aspects of SEO
primarily focusing on off page so these
are just some examples that we're going
to hone in on but this is just a small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of the these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's Keyword
Planner so here I am I'm in Google's
Keyword Planner and as I mentioned
before Google's Keyword Planner is
situated under Google ads okay so you
have to have a Google ads account to use
Google's keyboard planner and so when
you're in Google ads you simply go to
tools and then under Tools you're going
to select Keyword Planner so what we
want to do is look for keywords we're
focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so let's just use one of the
examples that Google's given us here
mail delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if I wanted to
but I'm asking Google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
I'm going to click click get results
notice I can add another keyer if I
wanted to but I'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that I can certainly hone
in on if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just tone in on that one
key word mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what Google Keyword Planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here I
get a column for competition so I'm able
to see whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
you an extra Edge when you're choosing
keywords you can get a sense of what the
keyword May cost if you wanted to bid on
that for paid search so for mail
delivery I can see it's anywhere between
$746 and at the top of the page high
range
$16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm going to try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
High competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit High well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know a dollar to $3 okay I
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the $7 they're suggesting so
that's a indication that the keyword is
highly competitive so the idea here
using Google's Keyword Planner is one we
want to get an idea of what other
keywords are out there that are relevant
so help stimulate some ideas for
relevancy two we can get an average
monthly search volume so we want to know
on average over the past 12 months how
many search queries I can expect from
this keyword and then three I can get a
sense of the competition how competitive
is this keyword so if I try to optimize
for this keyword and I want to rank for
it organically is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
Texas I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total us so you
have settings that you can change and
manipulate to get to the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a Moz account so I
logged into MZ and MZ has a tool called
keyword Explorer so if I use that same
keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask M
to give me some data on that keyword so
this is for the entire United States and
again I can change that if I wanted to
okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what m
is telling me hey for this keyword in
the entire United States I'm looking at
anywhere from
115,000 to 30,000 on monthly volume now
what Moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty scores
is a score between one and 100 and so I
can see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's 100 it's very difficult and
then that means you have a lot of
competitors who are optimizing for this
keyword that are ranking for this
keyword and so Moz gives us the volume
they give us the competition and they
just like Google's Keyword Planner gives
us some other keywords that we can
potentially hone in on so here I could
see keyboard delivery plans delivery
services Etc so I can see a lot more
suggestions than what's listed here so
MZ delivers a bunch of other analysis uh
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so Moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to Moz
related to SEO for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use Google's Keyword
Planner because maybe you're not running
Google ads you can always use Moz now
remember Moz has basically a freemium
version meaning you can sign up for a
free account and you could sign up for a
free account as a test trial and you
could test it for a period of days and
leverage its tools during that free
trial to get a better sense of how these
tools work so we want to be able to use
mods we want to be able to use Google's
Keyword Planner not only to search for
all those relevant keywords available to
you but we want to be able to choose
keywords with high volume and low
difficulty low competition we also want
to select primary and second keywords
wisely so remember when you optimize
you're optimizing a page for more than
one keyword so you want to be able to
have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Moz gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
uh to get more specific details about
using SEO tools for keyword research and
all about keyword research in general
for SEO so let's talk about some other
reasons under SEO why would would use
some of these tools available to us well
we want to be able to understand the
search engines and how they crawl and
index our site okay we also want to
check the correct format of the site map
and we want to monitor backlinks okay we
also want to analyze linking to our web
page okay which ones are good which ones
are not good okay we also want to
perform some competitor analysis so
these are some of the reasons why
other than keyword research why would
would we use some of these SEO tools so
we have tools available to us Majestic
HRS again M let's take a look at Google
search console and I want to hone in on
Google search console because it is free
and it's a must if you're going to work
on SEO you need to be working in Google
search console and so the whole key
behind Google search console is is you
have a website and you need to get that
site verified once it's verified once
Google can recognize that you are
associated with this website then you're
going to be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I could see I
have some issues with 112 pages and some
of those issues are listed down here so
there could be a crawl issue a 44 you
know redirect okay so you could see
there's some five unique issues across
112 pages so here I could see submitted
URL marked no index there's a hundred of
those pages we have some redirect errors
there's seven pages that you know fall
victim to this error and so we can
really hone in on what the error is and
address the error okay so if Google's
telling us hey this is an issue and you
want that page indexed by Google then we
should probably address the error and so
that's the great thing here about going
into Google search console is you can
under index go to coverage and get a
sense of what Google's indexing and what
they're not indexing so these are the
errors I can see they've certainly were
able to crawl an index
9,115 Pages uh they were able to crawl
okay and they excluded
54,000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
Pages index we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling is firsthand what the issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so you have an opportunity to
submit a sitemap and a sitemap is just a
formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it sitemap.xml XML being the
format so once you have this file you're
just going to let Google know that that
file exists so you're going to enter in
the sitemap URL so if it's in the root
directory all you're going to do is type
in sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what Google's going to do is say
hey look we see you've submitted this
and we last read it a couple days ago
and we could see that we discovered
1,419 URLs so I can go back under
coverage and I can see some of the
issues that they found but if I go back
under sit Maps I can see that these are
the URLs they discovered via the sit map
and so the whole point of a sitemap is
we want to be able to get and push the
URLs to Google not have Google come to
our site and discover them so this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with Google all the URLs
that you have on your site that you want
Google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report so Google is a
staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so they begin it on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps perhaps they'll go into a
store or perhaps they'll go via desktop
but Google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site faes Via
Mobile and when I say fairs Via Mobile
is it mobile friendly is it responsive
is it loading quick enough you know is
it formatted to Google standards and so
if there are any issues Google's going
to let you know what those issues are so
here I could see Google's recognized 206
pages with four different issues okay so
here I can see what those issues are
just like the coverage issues we can see
specifically what they are and so here I
can see for 206 Pages text too small to
read click elements too close together
the viewport not set to device wi and
then content wider than the screen so
there's 10 pages that fit under this
error and if I actually click on it the
error
I could see what those 10 pages are and
so when we're done we can actually when
we address the issues we can actually
have Google validate whether the fix has
been made so you can definitely use this
as a means of communicating directly
with Google telling Google look I see
what the issues are I'm going to fix
them and then I want you to validate
them okay so this is important because
if you can communicate with Google and
let them know hey we do recognize the
errors we are fixing the errors please
validate them you know it's going to
draw Google's attention Google's going
to validate them and get these Pages
index quicker um so if you ignore the
issues and the errors especially for
mobile then you stand the chance of your
pages not getting index so the mobile
usability report to me is an important
report because we want to better
understand whether Google's picking up
issues on mobile and if they are we want
to address them get Google valid them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report in
Google search consult shows us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the homepage has 26,000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I can see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console is giving me kind of an
overview of what my linking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so I'd be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
I think's of interest in Google search
console and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you can link up
with Google analytics so you could see
the same report in analytics if you're
able to link up Google search console
with analytics and you should be able to
do that all you need to do is make sure
you use the same email address that you
use for analytics and search console so
it needs to be the same email address
you could certainly link up the two and
have this data imported into Google
analytics so what is this data that
we're talking about well it's called
performance so what we can actually see
is the queries the actual queries people
are typing in to Google so when they're
typing them into Google we can actually
see how many Impressions the keyword
queries received and how many clicks the
keyword queries received and then I can
see click the rate and average position
okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword on the first line I
could see over the course of the last 3
months it re received
29,285 Impressions so what does that
mean that means this keyword was used at
Le or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 29,000 plus times
this site received 120,000 plus clicks
so so to get a sense of the click
through rate all you would need to do
and Google can obviously do this for you
is you would simply just divide the
[Music]
2092979267
so over half of the clicks occur when
this listing appears for this keyword
Okay so we can get a sense of the click
the rate for each one okay and you could
simply just use the filtering here now
we can also see average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to Pages we
can go from pages to countries so we can
get a sense of how many Impressions and
clicks I'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
I can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now I
mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I can
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I see
what my search queries are my clicks my
Impressions my click theate buy search
query and then the average position so
that's the great thing about that
performance report is that when I link
up Google search console with analytics
I'm able to see that data in analytics
so that's an added bonus so to speak now
let's talk about some other reasons why
we are going to use these SEO tools
available to us and so we already listed
a number of different reasons ranging
from
sit maps to keyword research but we also
want to hone in on you know what domains
are driving links to our site so I
showed you an example in search console
we also want to hey maybe identify and
disavow poor backlinks so search console
is a great tool for that because if we
don't want to be associated with a
particular website we can certainly
disavow that link we could track a
number of file follow and no follow
links okay we could track our website's
rankings we can measure clickthrough
rates and Impressions just as we did
with search console we could track
keyword ranking for desktop mobile cross
locations just as we just did with the
search console performance report we can
identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like MZ you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a Moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about MZ is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and onpage
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score out
of one and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as as well so
here if I click on the linking domains
I'm going to be act able to see the
actual domains pointing to my site as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look at
all the domains that are linking to me
and then I can highlight the ones that
have poor domain Authority what Moz even
takes it a step further they also give
me a Spam score so Moz is able to
measure how spammy a website is so if I
have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you could see here as I keep going
down for example I could see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16% so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this link Ling domains report is
I'm able to hone in on not only who's
link linking to me meaning domain but
how many linking domains does that
domain have what's the spam score of
that domain what's the domain authority
of that domain and then I can get into a
little bit more detail and I actually
see you know all the links pointing to
that domain so it really goes into
detail about backlinks domain Authority
spam Etc everything you need to use in
order to measure off page SEO so that's
the great thing about m is they have not
only onpage SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a premium so to speak
so here you can see if you just go to
mod.com free-- tools you'll be able to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for SEO but also for local SEO
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start start your free
30-day trial so I use and lean on Moz a
lot for all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords to rankings report to
checking issues on my website to even
checking who's linking to me so this
fits in the mold with everything I need
to do for SEO so in addition to that
keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on SEO so
we've done a webinar on SEO o tools and
we've also done a webinar on SEO tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or SEO in general take a look at those
two videos and check them out and that
should kind of complement what we talked
about with using some of the tools
Google's Keyword Planner uh MZ and
Google search console okay let's switch
over to email marketing tools and so
with email marketing tools
we have a lot available to us in the
form of reporting in the form of
Platforms in the form of you know tools
that really help us go from A to Z on
our email choosing you know what email
to send out to creating a list to
measuring how the email campaign went
and so we could start with MailChimp
because mail Champs a premium version
when we say premium meaning they have a
free trial available then you're
expected to upgrade but you know
MailChimp to me is a tool I use I like
the interface very easy for beginners so
we're going to take a look at MailChimp
but there are certainly many others
available you know Mar is a good tool
you know Mar is a good tool because if
you have a business and you're trying to
funnel people through your pipeline so
to speak meaning they they sign up as a
lead and you want to nurture that lead
from the beginning to the end meaning at
the end they're actually going to turn
around and purchase well Marc is a good
tool for you to use because you can then
set up trip campaigns or also known as
email campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about maretto it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's HubSpot is a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing page
to AB testing to social to you know
email so this is another premium tool
that you could use you have another
premium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convert kit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use Constant
Contact vertical response there plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comment section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you know different
tools because there are so literally so
many email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people use email on a on a daily
basis so it's no wonder why there's just
so many tools available and so with
these tools you could certainly send
bulky emails now in the case of mar you
could send emails to a segmented
audience and so that's a actually what
you want to do as a strategies always
send emails to a segmented audience you
know you want to use a tool where you're
going to be able to create campaigns
then send those campaigns to again
segmented contacts and then be able to
design your email around that particular
audience so you know you have a good
tool when you can do that when you can
really segment for your audience okay
you want to be able to use an tool
that's going to be able to segment your
users you know use transactional emails
meaning hey look if somebody go ahead
went ahead and purchased can you follow
up with an email and creating workflows
just like a mention with maretto you
want a workflow set up where a if
somebody does this you're sending email
B Etc so you want a email marketing tool
that's flexible enough to handle what
your business strategy and goals are
okay so you want to be able to also use
a tool that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to manage your list
appropriately meaning if you have 10,000
users or emails in a list you want to be
able to manage them accordingly you know
break them up or or have sub list so to
speak and then most importantly you want
want to make sure you have a platform
that not only does its tracking on its
own but will give you some detailed
insights meaning you know what
percentage of users opened your email
what percentage of of recipients clicked
on your email what links they click on
you know which which emails bounce so
you want some detailed insights right in
the platform that you're using it just
makes it more simpler and easier and
more effective to manage you certainly
want to create this smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time and day so these tools also allow
you to you sigment contacts based on GE
location you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multivariant
testing again you want to analyze
performance and optimize campaigns you
want to trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool will automatically send
that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use MailChimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
MailChimp so with MailChimp once you log
in you know you're going to be able to
see some historical campaigns that you
sent out or you're going to be able to
create your own campaign and so this is
kind of under campaign cign you can kind
of see an overview of the ones you've
sent out or if they're in draft mode
you'll be able to see they're in draft
mode so you can go ahead and edit them
so here we have one that was set up on
August 26th and it's still in draft mode
so we can go ahead and edit that so if
we just click edit you know we have the
flexibility to you know pick and choose
who we're sending this to who it's from
what the subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email
again this is important because with
email marketing you want to be able to
cater your email to your intended
audience so if you're selling men's
shoes your audience should be men okay
so you don't want men to receive an
email about women's shoes it sounds like
it's common sense but the point being
you want to be able to use an email
platform that's going to be able to
allow you to put two and two together
the message and the design
with the intended audience and so here
you can see MailChimp allows us to do
that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste your code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is is the reporting
okay so yes it is easy to choose a
template and map that template to your
audience but I really like the reports
that they have to offer so you know here
you could see there's some list that
we've sent to and if we choose one of
our audience list then we can see some
really detailed reporting here and so
here I could see this email that was
sent out in June I could see it was sent
to 95,000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers I saw 2,000 plus open it and
157 clicks so I can view this report in
more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so I
can get down really to the nitty-gritty
I can actually see you know on the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent two different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16% I
only had an open rate of 2.5% so the
industry average is 18% and so here I'm
able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers with
the most opens I can link social to it
if I want to and then I can see
geographic information so the point
being is MailChimp really goes into some
nice detail here about the email camp
aigns and how they performed so the
great thing is too with the mailchip you
can link it with Google analytics you
can link it with e-commerce okay so if
you have an email and you're you're
selling products and somebody purchased
that product MailChimp is able to
integrate in with your shopping Commerce
platform for example woo Commerce so if
somebody did purchase you can send out
that thank you email MailChimp even goes
a step further and if somebody did click
on a link go to your shopping cart card
add something to the shopping cart and
then abandon the card you know mailchip
allows you the opportunity to retarget
them via email so MailChimp is flexible
and that's what you want in a email
marketing platform you want something
that's flexible that you can cater to
your audience you can manage your
audience list and you can get detailed
reporting on your different campaigns
for that audience so that's mailchip in
summary and so most email platforms do a
lot of the similar features or have some
of the similar features but that's what
you ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform so here's a tool that
doesn't get talked about enough when it
comes to email marketing and that's
Google's URL Builder and the reason why
we're going to talk about this tool
today is because most people in the US
use Google analytics as their web
Analytics tool and the one thing about
Google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchip or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have have a
URL that says visit Florida and I'm
going to send out an email I have up to
five parameters that I can use okay so
here's my email or URL that I'm using in
the email so I have up to five
parameters that I can use to track this
particular email so let's go through
some of those parameters so the first
one is campaign source so what's the
source of the campaign well we could
certainly identify mail champ if we're
using mail champ as the source now the
the thing about the URL Builder you
always want to use lower case because
Google analytics is case sensitive so as
a rule of thumb just stick with a lower
case so our source is going to be
mailchip because that's the platform
we're using if you're using you know
Constant Contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one convert
kit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now the medium
which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so the summer promo here is visit
Florida beaches okay so we're going to
send this email out to the masses and
particularly not only the masses but the
masses in the north cuz we're going to
say hey look come to Florida for the
summer come visit our beaches that's the
point of the campaign so that's what
we're going to use for the campaign name
is whatever the campaign is it's a
summer promo now notice I got an
asterisk next to these particular
parameters so Google's asking us hey
these are mandatory so go ahead and put
something in there now for campaign term
and campaign content we could certainly
leave them blank because they're not
mandatory but since we're talking about
email I would certainly recommend that
you use the campaign content parameter
and why do I say that because if we're
sending an email out to say you have
10,000 recipients I want to be able to
split out the email into two segments
one segment that's going to get subject
line one and one segment that's going to
get subject line two so in this case I'm
going to put whatever subject line one
is in the campaign content field so now
I have four parameters
and once I've entered in my variables in
those parameter Fields I now have a
revised or pended URL so my original URL
was visit
florida.com us fl- bees. HTML my
original URL I've now appended that with
some UTM parameters and now I see my
original URL appended with the UTM
parameters based on those variables so I
can copy it just by clicking the copy
URL I can go to my browser I can paste
that URL in there and I want to check to
see if it works so here I could see this
particular page loaded Florida beaches
with my UTM parameters appended to the
URL so that's for the first subject line
that's for the audience that's going to
get the first subject line I want to do
another one for the second subject line
so now I'm going to to change my
campaign content parameter to subject
Line2 I'm going to copy that URL I'm
going to check it okay so I can see that
the page loads with those UTM parameters
and so now what am I going to do I'm
going to use the first URL and the
second URL in my email okay so any link
that I have in this case I'm using
subject line two so for the email with
the second subject line going to that
segmented audience this is the link I'm
going to use in the email so if you have
one or two or three links in the email
this is the URL you're going to use
because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in Google analytics so if I
jump over to Google analytics after I
sent out my email I'm going to go to
acquisition I'm going to go to campaigns
I'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables I put into my
parameters meaning Source medium
campaign name content or term that's
what I'm going to look for in Google
analytics so we could start with source
and medium so if I click on source and
medium as my primary Dimension here I
can see MailChimp and the actual date
was used as part of the variable for for
source and then I what can I see the
meaning being email so now I can see for
this email that was sent out in
MailChimp in May I can see how many
users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conversions so we
could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I can see exactly
what campaign what source what email
drove in traffic
and conversions and if I'm doing subject
line testing I can choose content as my
parameter so here I'm going to change it
to content and now I can see the subject
lines in this case if I go back to my
source medium I'm going to be able to
see what subject lines from my emails
generated the most traffic and not only
the most traffic but also conversions so
that's the whole point behind using the
URL Builder again you're taking a URL
that you're going to use an email and
then you're going to pan that URL with
different parameters campaign Source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended URL which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go go back over to
Google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that Medium of that
content IE subject line and so that's
why the URL build is so important
because MailChimp gives us some good
insight as to how the email performed in
terms of open and click rates but what
we really want to see is how that
campaign performed once it drove traffic
to my website so that's the whole idea
behind the URL Builder if you're using
Google analytics you'll be able to use
the URL Builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google analytics Google
analytics is a premium meaning that they
have a free version that you can use
there is also a paid version of Google
analytics but given the Advent of Google
it's popular especially in the United
States a majority of users are using the
free version of Google analytics so it's
a very popular tool especially for
marketers but there are also other tools
available so it's not just Google so we
have Adobe analytics which is also
fremium you have kiss metric you have
spring metrics you have YouTube
analytics which is part of Google but
YouTube has its own separate analytics
insights so a lot of these as you can
see are free to use they're available no
reason why you should not be using uh an
Analytics tool to measure your marketing
campaigns or website behavior and why
would we want to use these tools again
well again we want to really measure
Behavior we want to measure what's going
on with our website so we want to be
able to identify the location of where
our website visitors are coming from and
a lot of these analytics tools use IP
address to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
Target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country location we also want
to measure the engagement of our website
Behavior so we get traffic to the
website what are they doing how long are
they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use webing
Linux to to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50% new and 50%
returning cuz you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors cuz that means more traffic so
you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non- gooogle campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
a web Analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UT tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel spring
metrics you know they all work in a
similar fashion in that they're really
measuring website behavior and so if
we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look at each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience in Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
San Francisco California came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning user so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but they are providing you
with a good picture of who is coming and
when I say picture we have to paint that
picture and so if we look at say
demographics for example and I go to
demographics overview here's a picture
I'm painting well I can see that 25 to
34 year olds are the majority of the age
group that is coming to my website okay
I can see on the gender side of it I can
see that 63% of my traffic and again
this is year to date that I'm looking at
is coming to my website so 2/3 of my
traffic is female 1/3 male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34 so I'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well I can
also look at Geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
I go to location under goo I'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
I can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I can see
United States is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17%
from the US and then 16% from our
Argentina 133% from Mexico 10% from
India so we have a nice mix of traffic
from different locations in the world
coming to our website so that's Geo but
more importantly let's take a look at
mobile so if we go to mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they on a desktop or laptop are they
using their mobile device are they using
a tablet and so Google analytics breaks
it down very nice for you and so we
could see percentages and actual numbers
by device category and so in this case I
can see year to date I can see 62% are
coming from desktop 35% are coming from
mobile and so that's important because
most people start their Journey from
mobile and that is growing and that's
going to continue to grow so you want to
keep an eye on mobile so to me this is
one of the more important reports under
audience because people who come from
Mobile have a different not only
experience because the website should be
responsive to the mobile device but
their mindset is going to be different
they're actively looking for something
they're probably going to either then
follow up on their desktop or follow up
in person at your store or they're
probably looking for directions or they
may just call you so the experience is a
lot different on mobile so we want to
hone in on the growth of mobile okay so
to me this is one of the more important
reports in Google analytics especially
under audience so let's move on to
acquisition so acquisition reporting
tells us how the traffic was driven to
the website so if audience tells us who
is coming to the website acquisition
tells us how that traffic got to the
website and so really what you want to
do is get a sense of what channels what
marketing channels are are driving
traffic so remember we talked about
organic search well those search engines
are indexing your pages well how much of
that traffic from the search engines is
actually coming to your site and I'm a
Believer in if organic search is the
primary driver of traffic then you have
a pretty healthy website because that
means the search engines are indexing
your pages people are searching for
something related to your business
you're being found you're getting
clicked and that represents a majority
of the traffic so that's always a good
thing so here we could see it broken
down by Channel if I go to all traffic
channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72% of my traffic and this is year to
date then I can see paid search then I
can see direct which means Somebody went
directly to the site I can see referral
email social then I can see more paid
search broken out so these are the
different marketing channels now
analytics allows you to look at a
specific source and medium so the source
would be the actual web site or search
engine in the medium would differentiate
how that traffic actually got to the
site so we're talking about a search
engine did they come to the site via
paid search or did they come to the site
via organic search and so all we need to
do is change our primary Dimension from
default Channel grouping to source and
medium and we could see specifically the
breakout of the different sources and
mediums driving traffic to the site so
here I can see Google organic at
71% and then Google CPC or C per click
at 15 16% of our traffic so then I can
look down I could see email in here
being organic I could see some referring
sites I could see some social in terms
of mobile Facebook okay so we could see
mix of the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at Channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the Keyword
Planner in Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non Google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaign
drove traffic to the website so here I
can see vertical response email as a
driver of traffic so that's the campaign
reporting and then also if you have
search console so we looked at search
console earlier when we talked about SEO
tools well remember I said you can link
up search console with Google analytics
well here's search console and we could
see queries devices landing pages
countries so all the performance metrics
that we could see in search console
because we have it linked up with
analytics we could see it right here so
this gives us a nice snapshot of what
keywords are driving traffic to the site
organically I could see The Impressions
I could see the clicks then I could see
the click DeRay and then the average
position so in theory the higher
something ranks the more traffic you're
going to get so that's the idea behind
it we want to make sure that we're
ranking for our coveted keywords and if
we are we want to be able to measure how
many times our listing was seen and how
many times it was clicked so that's the
great thing about you know Google they
have a family of products and those
products tend to talk to one another in
the form of Google search console and
Google ads you can connect them directly
to Google analytics so let's move from
acquisition to behavior so here in
Behavior we have a number of different
reports so Behavior tells us once the
traffic actually arrived at the website
how are they behaving and so really what
I would do is from there go to site
content all pages and so this gives us
an idea of how many pages were actually
viewed so site content all pages tells
us what page and how many times it was
viewed during a period of time and again
we're looking at year-to dat so I can
see engagement related metrics
associated with a page so this
particular page here on line one I could
see how many pag VI unique Pags which is
equal to sessions so I can have a
session come to the website and look at
a page multiple times in that session I
could see the average time the person
has spent on a page and I can also see
the bounce rate so a bounce rate
indicates that they arrived on the page
and didn't go any further they left the
website from that page that they arrived
on and so I can also see percentage of
exits meaning what page did people exit
the site from so these are all
engagement related metrics so here is
where I want to react and optimize my
website performance so I if I see a page
not performing well meaning it has a
high balce rate or maybe low time on
page then I'm probably going to optimize
is it meaning test it or change it to
improve performance so these are all
pages but I could certainly look at
landing pages okay so landing pages
tells us the behavior of the page when
somebody landed on it so a landing page
means that somebody came from organic
search or paid search or another Channel
landed on this page so here I could see
this particular page on line one had
4,970 sessions okay and I can also see
the the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because pages and
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we want
to go to sight speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our Pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if a page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page low time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is an analyzing the page
as you could see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here I could see there's some server
respon time issues image sizes probably
need to be resized I can remove unused
CSS okay so there are a lot of different
things I can do to improve the page lad
time on this particular page okay this
is for desktop I can also see mobile so
mobile a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift in page low time
when you see a lift in page low time
we're going to probably see a lift in
organic rankings or even user engagement
because if a page takes a long time to
load a user is probably not going to
stay on that page very long so to me
sight speed is an important report under
Behavior now one more report here that I
want to point out under behavior is
events and to me events are important so
if you're trying to measure engagement
on your website you need to make sure
you have event tracking set up and when
we talk about event tracking we're
talking about measuring things that
analytics doesn't measure by default so
if you have a button on your website if
you have a PDF download if you have a
submit button on a form submission if
you have a subscribe button if you have
a video if you have an external link
anything that is going to trigger
engagement on your website you need to
measure with event tracking and event
tracking is simply set up by breaking
out the event into a category an action
and a label and so here we could see for
our particular website we have
categories already set up for event
tracking so here for example I can see
on line six video I can see how many
people actually watched our video okay
so here's the action video Start okay so
over this period of time I could see I
had 49 unique events 50 total so that's
how many people actually watch the video
and you can always revert to label and
that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if you
go to events under behavior and you
don't see any events listed you probably
need to get that set up and that is set
up through Google tag manager so what
you want to do is you want to be able to
set up your events through Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category an action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under Behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so I'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a PDF uh submitted a
form uh played a video did whatever we
wanted them to do so events are
important so let's move from Behavior to
conversions and this is important
because we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analytics
has four types of conversions so if I go
to admin down at the bottom and then I
go to goals I could see that I have four
different types of goals that I can use
now right now I have event related to
goals set up for the website for this
particular website so we just talked
about event tracking so if you're
measuring a button click on your website
you can certainly turn that into a goal
and so all you need to do is tell
analytics hey this is the particular
category this is the particular action
so for example if I click on this
particular goal and take a look at it I
can see that we have a category set up
that anything that resembles donate now
okay or donate go ahead and fire this
event as a conversion okay so event is
one type of goal another type of goal is
destination so if somebody goes to a
specific page like a confirmation page
we can turn that into a goal so here I
could see if somebody goes to donation D
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like Channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least 1 minute and 30 seconds or more
then analy is going to count that as a
goal conversion okay so duration is the
third type and then the fourth type is
pages per session okay so if I look at
this example here if a user came to my
website and looked at more than three
pages in that particular session then
analytics is going to fire a goal
conversion so four types of goals you
don't have to set up all four different
types my recommendation is at least have
one goal set up if you're not sure what
goal to set up then at least set up a
duration or pages per session okay so at
least you can measure how long somebody
stays on your website or how many pages
they went to okay so when you actually
do have these goals set up you can go
back into conversions we can go back
into goals we can go back into overview
and we can measure our goal completions
over this period of time so here I can
see 313 goal complet s total with a goal
conversion rate of
1.88% and then I can see it broken down
by goal type so remember the only goals
I have available and set up are event
related goals so 69 newsletter signups
156 donate click buttons I have 32
contact form submissions 37 email click
completions and then 11 phone number
click completions so I can measure
engage
as a goal and so goals generally are
important to the business so you want to
make sure that if you have a goal for
your website then you want to be able to
set that up as a goal in Google
analytics so that way when you're
looking at example channels if I go back
to my channels report I can then measure
Channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if I want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the Donate Now button
I could see that I could see year-to
date
10,887 users which meant 11,000 sessions
76 clicked on that donate Now button and
that's comes out to
65% conversion rate okay so that's
important so you want to be able to
measure any Dimension whether that be
Channel Source medium keyword campaign
mobile device could be
demographic uh gender or age you want to
be able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in Google analytics
again audience acquisition behavior and
conversions there a lot of data in
Google analytics but you want to be able
to take advantage of the data in order
to improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube if you
have a channel set up some playlist
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your vide is
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube Studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
I can see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8,600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over
177,000 and I've netted 48 subscribers
and this is an overall
okay so I can actually see when I
publish videos and I can see the date
they were published and here I'm looking
at you know total views over this
particular date range I can also see
specifics on a particular video so I
could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click the rate so here I can
see the different traffic sources so 29%
came externally okay here I can see 25%
came within YouTube itself I could see
how many times a video was viewed and
played via playlist via suggested video
so I can see different ways in which the
traffic found my video and actually
watched it here I can see externally how
people were able to find my videos and I
could see 46% found it via Google search
see some lots of information here uh
about sources of traffic how the traffic
got to these videos so I could see then
once the traffic found my videos how
many times they actually saw it and
viewed it and then watched it so that's
how many times I was able to reach
viewers via different sources and then
their reaction to that how many times
they saw it and watched it here I can
click on interest viewers so again I
could see the top videos in terms of
watch time I could see the top playlist
so here I could see my partners playlist
was the top playlist so I can see some
interest here in terms of average View
ation and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I can see 88% of
the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them but they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to conone in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
YouTube Analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some indepth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spy tools very important
to keep tabs on what the comp
competition's doing and there are a lot
of tools out there so when it comes to
social we can use a premium tool like
Sprout social to listen in on our
competitors we can use another fremium
tool social blade there's a popular tool
out there called spyfu that's freemium
as well MZ we looked at Moz earlier for
keyword organic Moz is a great tool for
also leveraging our competitors in terms
of back links and Buzz Sumo so that's
that's another freemium tool again there
are lots of tools out there these are
just examples of some of the tools that
we use here to Simply learn I use
personally and professionally to get a
sense of what our competition's doing so
why would we want to use a competitor
spine tool well it may sound like a very
straightforward question but there are
lots of reasons why and so let's look at
some of these reasons and the first
reasons we really want to identify you
know our competitor's backlinks and
monitor change es in the ranking so the
reason why we have this is the top
bullet point is because SEO organic
search is a longterm strategy on page
off page website very techical and
creative there's a lot going on with SEO
a lot going on and sometimes it takes a
long time to rank for something and a
lot of SEO does depend on relevancy
relevancy being how many quality back
links are linked to you so it's always
good to leverage what your compe
competitors are doing so you could see
how you stack up and so that's why this
is up there as number one we want to be
able to really take a look at what our
competitors are doing another example
would be hey how much uh traffic a
competitor is gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competitions doing
okay we can also identify our
competitor's top performing content for
Relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitor website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our
competitor's data and compare it with
our own campaigns so lots of tools out
there to help you do this and we may
want to track the total amount of clicks
a competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ah and
take a look at a few examples how we can
leverage all these these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with Sprout social
and Sprout social is a tool I use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with Sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
a post that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example RV rental
in Twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about RV rentals so we could do
this for Twitter we could do it Facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on Sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put in a
brand name we're just going General here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals Cruise America RV we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting TW or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay I can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
I can scroll down and I can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and I can see a lot of
people are as an example retweeting this
particular giveaway and so to me it just
gives me a sense in this particular
example on Twitter
as to what are competitors doing okay
let's turn our attention to SEO so
remember that first bullet point we want
to get a sense of what our competitors
are doing when it comes to backlinks and
so Moz has a great tool called link
Explorer and Link Explorer there allows
us to actually compare link profiles so
for my domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know how
many links my competitors have external
inter internal I can get a sense of the
domain Authority I can get a sense of
page Authority linking domains so I can
really do a a comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this gives me an overview
of everything I need to know organically
now MZ also has another great tool under
link Explorer called link intersect and
and I like link intersect I use it a lot
because if our competitors really have a
number of external links and domains
pointing to their site and they have a
better domain Authority and Page
Authority then you know I want to be
able to you know see what they're doing
where they're linking who's linking to
them I want to get be able to get a
snapshot of why is their domain so much
better than ours in terms of authority
and so the link intersect actually
allows me to do that so I can go ahead
and put my competitor domains in there
and then I can find Opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
could see where my site intersects with
their site and if it doesn't actually
intersect then I have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then I have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the L
link intersect tool is in mods it allows
me to really get a sense of you know
where I'm linking and where my
competitors linking now what we can also
do is also take advantage of another
report under moz's link Explorer and the
discovered and loss report so we could
put in our domain or we could put even
our competitor's domain in there and can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within mods
we can get a good snapshot of what web
sites are linking to our competitors we
get a good snapshot of the overall links
to our competitor sites and specifically
what sites so the whole idea is if it's
good for our competitors meaning they're
linking from a site that has good domain
Authority and low spam score then it's
probably a site I want to be able to
tackle as well well okay so you have
discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in mz's
link Explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in MZ and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitor's
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain Authority
is Page Authority for the homepage but
really this is what're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9,000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain Authority I could sort
by domain Authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here I can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
Reddit here which is a good site for
backlinking New York Times so you know
there's a lot of different uh sites here
Washington Post so I can get a a good
snapshot of my competitor by seeing
every link that's pointing to them now
of course I don't want to go through
9,000 links I can really just hone in on
a specific link Source or link type or
link state so I can really filter it if
I wanted to I can export the report and
do some further analysis but really the
whole idea here as I can see what URL is
linking to this particular competitor
site with the anchor text is what the
page and domain Authority is so this
gives me a really really good Insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need to be on Reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from Reddit which has a domain authority
of 90 then hey if it's good good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links is just another
good report you can leverage in MZ under
the link Explorer reporting tool now if
I want to get a good snapshot as to what
my competitor is doing on search exactly
well look no further than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a PPC SEO perspective you know from
an SEO perspective you got some
backlinking data as well just like you
did Moz from a PPC perspective you can
get some good keyword insights and so
here I just went ahead and typed in the
domain and what this is going to do is
just give me an overall snapshot for my
competitor's domain so here I could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the estimated monthly
SEO clicks they're getting based on the
volume of those keywords okay I can see
here the keywords their top competitors
also rank for the rank history 12 years
so this particular domain's been around
a long time okay so that's on the
organic side I can flip over to the paid
side and I could see that they are doing
paid search I could see 5,000 plus
keywords they're bidding on he based on
that what they're actually paying and
then I could see you know some of the
other competitors listed here from a
paid perspective and organic perspective
I could see the shared keyword overlap
okay now again you can pay for this
because it's premium and get some really
good insights as to how your domain
compares to your competitors so I'm
using the free version and here the free
version spy fu is just giving me some
overall data on the specific domain I
entered in and so I entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is Google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you could see some
even some Google ads history I can see
exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then I can see some organic ranking
history here as I keep scrolling down
this overview report so I can see for RV
rent where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spy so spy gives
you kind of an overview for free some
really in-depth analysis if you actually
pay for it and it just really hones in
on what your competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic wise and so spy is a really good
tool to leverage if you just want to get
a snapshot of how your competitor uh
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to Google analytics because in
Google analytics under audience I can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous dat so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
is sharing
8,863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8,000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust in we can
adjust our local and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're going
to go with
4,999 and so we could see there are
about you know 300 something web
properties contributing 47 web
properties now now contributing to this
report so if we're focused on the New
Zealand region and this is the amount of
traffic we get we're now comparing us
against 47 other Anonymous web
properties so now if I go back to the
report after I've honed in I'm looking
at channels and I could see how many
sessions we're getting by channels and
how I compare against the competition I
can also measure up against percentage
of new sessions new users pages per
session average session duration bounce
rate but that's just channels I can also
do location and devices so the whole
idea behind this report is yes you're
not honing in on a particular competitor
but you're honing in on your industry so
you're getting a good idea as to how you
compare against your industry just by
making some adjustments in the
benchmarking report you obviously want
to make sure you're looking at the same
industry adjust for your country or
region adjust for the site size meaning
how many sessions you actually get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest they'll compare you against
those in your industry and so I find
this to be a good tool because it allows
me to stack up our site against those in
the industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a
keyword and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I can see some organic search
results okay if I scroll down I'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same key word meaning they're
paying for RV rentals so if I clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay Google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually trying
to rank for this keyword or trying to be
found for this keyword so that's all I
did I just did a search now from an
organic perspective if you really want
to hone in on your competition you can
always do the syntax all and title colon
and then hit enter so now I could see I
have 163,000 results and what does that
tell me that tells me that I have
163,000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have
163,000 different listings ahead of you
that you need to jump over in order to
rank for the keyword RV rentals so using
the All entitle syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keyword so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax and
you can see for RV rentals I have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
key word RV rentals in the title Tag and
Title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind using the All and
title syntax it gives us a good idea to
what our competitions doing and how many
sites we have to jump over to get to
number one on Google Now if you're
running Google ads just as we did with
RV rentals we went up there and we saw
we typed that in as a qu and we saw how
many advertisers there were for RV
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year to date and here we can see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
can see impression share so for if we're
talking about one key word every keyw
has 100% impression share how much of
that impression share are you getting
and when we say impression share meaning
eyeballs when we talk about eyeballs are
we getting a majority of the eyeballs or
are competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position I can see how often I overlap
with my competitors okay I could see how
often I'm above a particular competitor
I could see what percentage I'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then I
can see how often I outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so I can see all
this good insight as to what competitors
are big on the same keywords I am okay
so this is if you're running Google ads
okay so if you're running Google ads
okay you can just click on the auction
insights report you can find that the
top navigation just by clicking on
campaigns and by doing so you'll be able
to gain some insights as to where you
stack up from a paid search perspective
against your competitors so let's turn
our attention to paid marketing tools so
if you're doing some advertising on
Google Bing LinkedIn you probably want
to work within those platforms as the
tool of choice so you know if you're
doing paid search on say Google
search.com or display you could be doing
display advertising on you know a
network like ad roll or Google or you
could be doing social media paid ads say
on Facebook so whatever it is you're
doing you probably want to work within
that platform itself to get the ideal
data that you need okay so here are some
of the tools some of the places you can
go of course if you're work in Google
ads you also have Google ads editor that
you can leverage okay and I'll show you
that in a couple minutes you have Google
ads Keyword Planner of course both of
these are paid if you're running
campaigns okay so Bing if you're running
campaigns on Bing okay you get all this
good data that you can digest through
some reporting okay you also have some
third party tools out there that you
also have to pay for in wordstream okay
so word streams a thirdparty tool that
you can leverage Bing and Google are
actual advertising Network so you would
advertise on the platform itself and get
all the data you need right in the
platform and leverage a lot of the tools
that they have available in the platform
as I mentioned you could also use Google
ad editor uh so Bing also has their own
editor as well so and as well as
Facebook so you can use an editor type
version and I'll show you that here in a
couple minutes but let's talk about why
we want to use the tools in the platform
itself well we want to be able to
monitor how our ads performing so which
ad receives the most traffic as an
example we want to identify keywords
that are performing for us okay so our
keywords converting not converting or
they cost us a lot of money and not
netting a high enough return for us so
we want to keep an eye on that okay so
we want to monitor our cost okay across
different locations and devices not only
cost but we want to also monitor how our
ads are performing across different
locations of devices keywords across
different locations in devices so we
want to be able to measure by device
okay so we also want to analyze
competitor data and as we showed you in
the competitor section Google as an
example has auction insights reporting
analytics has benchmarking so Google
itself does provide some information in
the case of auction insights as to how
uh your competitors are performing
against you on Google search so that's
on the paid search side then you have
display okay so display advertisements
okay you're across a different network
so there are different types of networks
out there for example ad roll okay you
have ctio SRA is another paid version of
or paid tool you can use in wide orbit
so these are some of the paid marketing
tools you can leverage of course I like
to stay if I'm advertising on Google I
like to stay uh in Google ads and
measure my display performance that way
but if you're on ad roll for example
then you want to leverage ad roles
reporting platform and some of the tools
they have to offer so if we look at
display why do we want to leverage some
of these tools well just like search for
example where we want to look at keyword
and AD performance same kind of concept
here we want to be able to monitor
whether we have the right keywords and
right customer engagement so when when
it comes to display we want to be able
to make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
at not only audience insights but our
Target insights as well are we reaching
the Right audience when it comes to
display and Google has a good breakdown
that I'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that and that's on the display
side and if we look at Social okay why
what tools can we use on social well you
got Facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso qu tweey you got all these cool
paid search tools again I usually stick
with where I'm advertising so if I'm
advertising on LinkedIn or Twitter I'm
going to leverage that platform but just
know that there are other tools
available for you so a social like
display it's all about targeting our
audience so for these some of the tools
like on Facebook we can review and
relaunch our ad campaigns based on
target audience we can can measure
conversions and gain insights in this
example about Facebook users how are our
users per interacting with our ads and
then we want to Target People based on
their activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel PR preferences Etc
so social allows us to do that and then
with Facebook as an example we can
monitor any AB test we run for example
if we're running call to action test we
can measure the results of that right in
face Facebook and I'm going to show you
an example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into Google ads and look at
some tools available to us from the
search side of the house so if we're
running search campaigns right in Google
ads we could see campaign data we could
see keyword data we could see ad data so
for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks click
through rates Etc and so that way I can
go ahead and pause ads activate ads so
that's right here in the Google ads uh
platform itself now if I want to look at
specific keywords I can do that so I can
see what keywords are driving traffic
and clicks here I can just sort by
clicks and now I can see not only what
keywords are driving clicks I could see
what the click the rate is I can see the
Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm bidding on I
could see how much I've paid by keyword
and more importantly I want to be able
to see conversions or conversion rate
and then with Google ads you have
quality score so we want to be able to
measure quality score so this is uh
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
Great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular particular ad
and so if I see a keyword query that I
don't particularly care to be shown for
or want my ad shown for then I can go
ahead and just select it and I can add
it as a negative keyword okay so that
tool is available to you right in Google
ads okay and then you have the auction
insights so we' reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords and what their
impression share is what their average
position is what the overlap rate is
position above rate top of page absolute
top of page right out ranking sh so once
we have Google has data then they'll be
able to share that information with you
okay so that's just key wordss but
there's a cool tool that I really like
and I leverage it for SEO and paperclick
and that's Google's Keyword Planner so
if you click on tools and then you click
on Keyword Planner we'll be able to
Leverage The Keyword Planner and the
whole idea behind the Keyword Planner is
do we want to discover new keywords or
for the keywords we have selected we can
get volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
of volume I'm going to get and how much
I can expect to pay so now once I've
added my keyword to that plan I can go
ahead and and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of $2 so I can go ahead and
adjust my plan accordingly if I want to
in order to see basically how much I can
expect to spend so that's the whole idea
behind the Keyword Planner in terms of
choosing new keywords and once you
choose keywords you're interested in on
you can actually do a forecast to see
exactly how much you can expect to spend
how many clicks how many Impressions you
can expect to get and if you have
conversion set up how many conversions
you can expect to receive so that's all
part of Google's keyword plan that's
viewing forecast as well as choosing
keywords so there are so many different
tools and features within Google ads we
need a whole whole segment just on this
so so really I'm just going to highlight
some of the more important tools and
features so I mentioned the Keyword
Planner I mentioned the campaigns
keywords and ads reports another thing I
would look at in Google ads again we
mentioned this as one of our key
defining why would we use it bullet
point and that's because of devices so
we mentioned devices why would we use
Google ads reporting tool because we
want to look at devices and we want to
be able to see what devices are driving
traffic from what campaign and then the
cool thing about Google ads is right in
Google ads platform you can go ahead and
do a bid adjustment so if I increase my
bid adjustment for example on mobile
phones then my particular ad in this
particular campaign is going to show
more than on computer so I can always
decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
right in Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices while you also
have locations too so we mentioned that
as one of the reasons why we want to use
some of these tools and if I see a
particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bid
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned in search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your C with your
campaigns on locally so you're making
changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I could see the ad groups here okay so
for example I just wanted to turn off
all these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status Ena to PA
and I can revert back if I want to okay
so you can make hous changes so here I
can see the campaign the add group level
if I choose an add group then I can see
some keywords and again I can make
changes at nauseum here I can copy I can
paste I can delete okay so I can make a
lot of changes really quick right in
Google ads editor and that's the whole
point of editor is to go ahead and work
locally while somebody else is working
locally on the same account you could
both be working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent changes so if I
say get recent changes to all campaigns
what Google editor is going to do is
contact Google ads in the cloud and
download all those changes so here I can
see the changes being download in editor
from Google ads and when it's done it's
going to highlight all the changes that
have been made and so once I'm done
reviewing those changes I can go ahead
and click done and now I know I have the
recent latest changes in editor so now I
can go ahead and continue to make some
changes and when I'm done making changes
I can go ahead and post them so that's
the beauty of Google ads editor Bing has
a version Facebook has a version it
allows you to again go with the keyword
level the ad group level okay you can
look at ads itself and make changes to
the ads okay you could do a lot of
different things right an editor in fact
you could do pretty much most of what
you can do in Google ads you can do in
Google ads editor and so that's Google
ads Editor to me I would recommend it if
you're experienced with Google ads again
it's software you have to download it
you're going to use it on your computer
as software but when you make changes
all you need to do is post those changes
or get recent changes that have been
made on Google ads and so that's Google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into Google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform is
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
Network as well as for the Display
Network writing Google ads so if I want
to take a look at a campaign and AD
group on the Display Network I could
just click on that ad group and I can
look at the ads that are running for
that particular ad group on the Display
Network so here the difference being on
the display network is you can use image
ads on the search Network you can only
use text ads so here I can look at image
ads and I can see how they're performing
in fact you could even go a step further
and use responsive display ads so Google
has responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
Impressions click theate Etc right on on
my ads and extensions report in Google
ads platform now this happens to be ret
targeting campaign so if we click on
audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences is we're targeting here okay
so when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up what audience is performing
best okay so here I can see a Breakout
by audience again I could see the same
metrics I could see on the search side I
can see clicks Impressions click the
rate more importantly I want to be able
to measure conversions
okay so that's the whole idea when
you're in these platforms and you're
paying for ads is you want to be able to
measure against conversions and you can
also measure against cost per conversion
conversion rate okay so those are some
key metrics to measure up against
whether it's audience keyword ad
whatever the dimension is so here on the
Display Network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
Network the Display Network allows us to
demographic data and so now I could see
an age breakout or an age range breakout
that Google provides us and I can see
again based on the age range breakout
which age range has the most clicks
Impressions Etc including conversions so
you also have the opportunity on the
Display Network to add keywords you have
the opportunity to add topics and you
have the opportunity to see placements
or run placements so here if I click on
where ADS have shown I can actually see
where my ads have shown up for this
display campaign and Google ads allows
you the ability to go ahead and you can
exclude it from the ad group or exclude
a specific placement from a campaign so
you could take action on a specific
placement and I can see the type of
placement whether it's a mobile app
whether it's a site I can go ahead and
see exactly where that placement was so
that's the
placement report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising I
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on Google ads okay
so take a look at the Google ads
tutorial we have set up on YouTube okay
if you search for Google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good uh tutorial on
everything related to Google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you you could see just how
powerful it is and all the different
features that are available so take a
look at the video it's a nice
complimentry video to this one this
digital marketing tools and this will
give you a nice in deeper insight into
everything that's available on Google
ads and if you have any tools or
features on Google ads whether it's the
search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into uh
Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
adets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have left side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two adets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the app and then
I can see the cost per click here at 1
as an example and so now I can go in and
I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the creatives I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has uh
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you could see
here I could see some standard reports
by ad add set age and gender and then I
can see all reports here listed out by
placement by placement and device time
of day country Etc so if we just look at
age and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so you can
see by campaign I'm looking at all
campaigns here and I'm looking at just
age and gender I can certainly Des
select one of these and I can look at a
specific time range so now I could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here I could see 35 to 44 female I could
see the reach Impressions and how often
they're actually seeing my ad now this
is key for Facebook because if
somebody's seeing your ad a lot they're
probably going to tune out to it so
that's what makes the frequency metric
so important on Facebook because then we
can go ahead and you know turn off that
particular age and gender if we needed
to and we can see how much we spent so
this just gives you some idea of the
type of reporting that's available in
Facebook ads manager now the great thing
about Facebook uh reporting an ads
manager is you know I can group or
ungroup uh my Dimensions if I needed to
I could change the view and arrange
columns I can get rid of columns just as
you would in Google ads reporting very
similar stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you can pick and choose as
well okay and you got lots of different
flexibility when you're looking at the
reports on how your campaigns are
performing now here I can pick and
choose
I can choose campaign adet ads objective
again I can choose different
demographics so I have a lot of options
available to me in terms of how I want
to you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my
adset or my ad now remember if you're in
Facebook you can always go in and edit
the campaign you can edit the adset
remember in the adset that's where a lot
of your decision are going to be made
including how you want to drive the
traffic okay what your budget is okay
you can basically choose your audience
here so you're going to be able to
choose what type of campaign it's going
to be and based on that campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit an ad remember you can do AB
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you wrri in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
Facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and Facebook ads
manager check out the Facebook ads
tutorial
2019 a webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on Facebook
called Facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to Facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
Facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing lot of affiliate marketing
platforms out there the number one
probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ they're an affiliate
platform they have an a premium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically you're going to have to move
on and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate Market Maring
a lot of platforms out there click Inc
AWI so a lot of these are Brokers per se
and when I say Brokers like for example
with CJ you as a merchant or you as a
publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you need really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and and a lot of lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually going
to take a look at CJ and go through some
of the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know Affiliates
inflows employees other Advocates you
want to partner with so again you could
be on the merchant side you could be
actually selling a product and you're
going to want some somebody to help you
sell that product somebody with a
website who's an influencer who drives a
lot of traffic to their own site who you
know does sell reputable brand Etc so
you need somebody to help you introduce
you to these sites okay so CJ and some
of these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to do the
introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with Affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am I only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're going to want to be able
to set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you could set up
a terms and conditions for say 10% off
all sales as an example okay well you're
going to need a platform that will help
you broker that contract okay contract
terms or program terms furthermore
you're going to need a platform to help
you track hey is this affiliate helping
me drive traffic or is this affiliate
driving traffic to my products and is
this affiliate helping me sell so these
platforms help you do just that okay so
you can gain High website rankings with
the help of your affiliate meaning that
hey your affiliate can be promoting your
product and if they're promoting your
product you have a chance to show up via
paid search organic search off other
websites so social so you have a lot of
benefits to working with affiliate
marketing in itself and the tools
available will help you gain website
rankings as one example we want to be
able to track certain metrics okay so in
affiliate marking you have earnings per
click EPC as an example most platforms
measure EPC from a 7day period to a 3mon
period okay you can also figure out what
the actual cost per click is just like
you do on say Google search you can
actually measure that in affiliate okay
you want to eliminate fraudulent clicks
Impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many pressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
Impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so these platforms are
really built on helping you manage your
relationship with the affiliate by
offering up all sorts of reports and
tools you know the other big benefit
here to affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody somebody see our product
did somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience it's similar to
yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publishers link so we're going to click
on the Publishers link and remember when
you sign up Publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember you
could set up your own program term for
any publisher so as a best practice if
you have Publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know These Guys these Publishers get
better program terms versus say other
Publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
Publishers is performing well sweeten
the deal offer them a better program
terms and so you can align Publishers
with different program terms and and so
that's the whole idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
Publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get aligned
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you could
see here the term status whether it's
active or not earnings basically what
they've sold over the last basically 7
days or 3 months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym
EPC this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically CJ calculates you know how
much your Publishers actually making per
click you know just like paid search
we're paying Google X amount per click
and it's the same thing here we can't or
these Publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an EPC model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click CJ does it over a 7day period and
over a 3mon period so you could sort
based on 7day or 3 month to see who's
earning the most per click in terms of
Publishers now you can select underp
Publishers groups now you can group
group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into to a group
called Canada why because they're based
in Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea behind affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get aligned with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are best performing Publishers or
by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the the option to create publisher
groups because the whole idea again I'm
going to repeat it is you want to get
Publishers and you want to start
building your base of Publishers because
the more Publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so if you have Publishers who
are promoting your product for you then
you have a good opportunity to sell it
so the more Publishers you have on board
for the better the opportunity so now
once you have Publishers you can start
grouping these Publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in CJ to group Publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email
you know web analytics it's just
appropriate to finish up with social
media because social media has so many
tools available so many okay the first
one I can think about here is hoot hoote
is a great social media marketing tool
to use okay it's a premium okay you can
set up a free trial here you you
basically a base account and then uh you
can use hoot site to do a lot of things
anything from setting up landing page
PES to actually publishing content to
listening who tweet to me is one of the
most powerful social media marketing
tools available you got buffer buffer is
a paid version but you can actually set
up a low cost or free account actually
on Buffer and then move to a paid
account okay you got tweet deck been
around a long time that is actually free
and I would recommend tweet deck and
we're going to take a look at that here
in a couple minutes okay and then you
got Sprout social Sprout social is
another social Market marketing platform
similar to hoot week do a lot of
reporting a lot of publishing you can a
lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at Sprout social today as
well before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to smartly efficiently you know
schedule a manage your post okay so
you're not just working likely with just
one platform like Facebook you're
probably on a number of different
platforms depending on your business
depending on your bandwidth depending on
what you're selling your products Etc
your audience obviously has a lot to do
with it you know it could be Instagram
Pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that and manage it in
one place and that's what social media
marketing tools do they allow you to
manage everything in one place so if you
can manage everything one place then
these social media marketing platforms
need to be able to make it easy for you
to add and manage different accounts
okay so a lot of them have the ability
for you to add you know not just one
Twitter account but multiple Twitter
accounts and not just one social media
platform but multiple social media
platforms and a good social media
marketing tool worth its weight will
help you monitor the results so monitor
social media posts that help Drive leads
and sales in other words you're going to
have a lot of different metrics
associated with each social social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job okay so you want
to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform you just log into
one place get a sense of what's been
posted what the engagement is did they
purchase Etc and what you want to do is
be able to individually customize every
social media post across different
platforms so it just makes it a lot
easier to do that in these social media
marketing tools okay you don't want to
send out a blanket message across
different platforms you want to be able
to go ahead and customize a post
depending on what that post is depending
what the product is what time of day
what target market what target audience
so customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listen listening is a good
thing with social media marketing tools
using the listening functionality so you
can actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on Real Time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so so you're going to be able
to see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprout social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's a
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that platform
is going to have its own metrics if you
will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook Insight so
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent post so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads he you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into sprout social I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log in in Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I can see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is already in Facebook
insights so if it's available on
Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we can publish and schedule content
accordingly so all we have to do is
Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do could schedule it
for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila schedule so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to be look at the behavior of
it so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on once something got published you
could see the reaction of it and react
to it so another thing here that I like
about is spout social heat Suite A lot
of these other platforms do it really
well well you got listening tools so you
can listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivery on
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is Sprout social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example ex Le I'm in later.com
so later very similar to spout social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1:15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
Prof file that I want to publish to so
it just makes it that much easier and I
can visually see it and that's important
so here I can click on media library so
the one thing about later.com is that
you know you have a library of images
that potentially you can reuse so if I
click on this image here okay I can get
a sense of when it was used and I can
view it on a calendar I can add a label
for it so that's another benefit to
later is that they have this media
library here they have conversations so
I can actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being had similar to The Listening tool
in Sprout social and they have analytics
so you can actually see right in
later.com how your particular social
media platform is performing so I can
see it here over seven days I can see
the number of followers have increased I
can see the growth rate I can see the
number of Impressions that I've received
D okay so I want to be able to see how
my particular platforms performing over
a period of time so I can look at reach
the lot profile views website clicks
okay so I can get a lot of good insights
here right in the analytics platform of
later you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments Impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag has been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet dech so what
tweet dech does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see you
got the Cricket World Cup you got you
know the soccer football World Cup going
on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging or using
that hash Friday feeling in their tweets
and so the whole idea behind you know
tweet deck it it serves up a interesting
overview so to speak of not only your
account but you know a specific topic or
what's trending or you know other things
that are being said so if you really
want to pay attention to your brand or
something really specific like you know
your competitors or a specific product
then you can just do a search on that
and so that's the great thing about
tweak deck it allows you to kind of just
look and listen in on everything going
on in Twitter now we do have a good
video out here on YouTube how to start
social media marketing so if you haven't
had a chance to look at it take a look
it goes over some of these tools that we
cover today like sproutsocial later.com
you know Facebook insights so it does
cover in more detail some of what we
covered on these social media marketing
tools so take a look at how to start
social media marketing so we covered a
lot of different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plugin if you will so I can go and take
a look at a spec a specific video and
see how many hours it's been watched how
many views minutes watch subscribers Etc
you know the great thing here I can look
at the entire entire account so I can
get good insights into my video or my
entire account here just by adding in
the vid IQ extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because it's good
for video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content on your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site check up or site analyzer these
are pay tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third party tool so these are good tools
to use for Content optimization you know
there's also other key Reddit but you
know there's Keyword Planner uh in
Google there's also uh word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a Google
ads platform and so if you don't have
Google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to Google's Keyword Planner
so having a thirdparty keyword tool will
pay dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only payperclick but also SEO and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in Social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
Reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in Google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts SEO so
there are other tools available you you
got a third party tool here that's free
solar winds pingdom you actually have
page Beed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of and determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
zaret okay so I'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotjar.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with a
free account you can have hotar measure
the heat map not only the heat map but
the click mapping the scrolling of a
particular page and so here you could
see we're looking at a particular page
here so hot jar allows me to you know
see on that page where people are
clicking um I can also see where people
are moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you could see here on the page I could
see people are moving over here to the
right that's where they're clicking Mo
mostly if I switch over to move mode
then I can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
Mouse and then I have my scroll analysis
so I could see you know how far down
people actually scroll on the page and
so again with a paid account you can
measure up to 10,000 page views with the
free version you can measure up to 2,000
page views and so 2,000 pag VI allows
you to get some insight as to what
people are clicking on or where they're
moving or how they're scrolling on a
particular page and so I definitely
recommend hot jar they also do funneling
they also do forms poll
lots of other tools available in hot jar
so hotjar.com is a tool I would
recommend as well so one final tool and
I'd be remiss if I didn't mention it and
that's Google optimize so Google
optimize is a Google platform that
allows you to AB test and so AB testing
means that you have an original page and
you're changing one element on that page
to see which one performs better and so
with Google optimize it's just very easy
to set up to run and the whole point of
Google optimize and AB testing is to
improve website performance so here you
can see I have an account set up and
optimize you can see we're running one
test here and we're just testing one
element versus the original so we move
photos to the top of the page the
original didn't have the photos to the
top of the page and so we can go into
reporting here Google optimize does all
the heavy lifting and so here you could
see we can look at bounces or we can
look at you know basically a measure the
test up against the metric that's
important to our business and again the
whole point is to improve website
performance and so definitely take a
look at Google optimize we'll have
another webinar in the future on the
topic but you know to me Google optimize
is free you can run up to five test okay
and if you can run up to five different
tests then that means you have the
ability to really improve improve
website performance okay so Google
optimize is a tool that I would
recommend today we're going to talk
about why you would want to rank using
SEO and SEO is search engine
optimization also known as organic
search you also May ass heere a say
organic listings but we're going to talk
a little bit about why you'd want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does Google rank websites so why does it
rank one website over another and how do
we get our website to rank number one
then we're going to talk about the
different types of SEO or search engine
optimization techniques so you can get
your website ranked number one and then
we're going to finish that off with the
dos and don'ts of SEO until next time
thank you and keep learning stay tuned
for more from Simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here